You know for a second I
thought you're this other guy
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my mandalorian season 2 episode 7 video
bill burr was back so we'll break it all down to
a whole bunch of star wars easter eggs and because
of the disney investor day announcements we
learned about a bunch of the star wars live-action
disney plus series that they're doing in the
next couple of years in the mandalorian spin-offs
if you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get everything obviously i will be doing videos
for the other spin-off episodes when they do
premiere in future years i'll explain that at
the end of the video too after we talk about this
episode probably one of the biggest announcements
they made was that hayden christensen is coming
back as darth vader during the obi-wan kenobi
series everybody freaked out about that careful
for spoilers for everything that's happened on
the mandalorian so far we'll do top 10 wtf and
easter eggs as we go along starting with number
10 the title of the episode is the believer it's
a reference to both bill burr's character and
mando because bill burr's mayfield character spent
the entire episode trying to compare them on a
philosophical level and say how they're so much
alike see you're just like me mando when the going
gets tough they both do what they have to to sleep
at night changing their rules because the mando
changed a lot of his core rules as a mandalorian
a member of the watch or death watch so to speak
so i'll address that when we get to that part of
the episode because the armorer is still alive
so you have to wonder what she's going to say to
this when she finds out what he did but you also
have bill burr's character trying to write some of
the wrongs that he did previously as an imperial
sharpshooter during operation cinder you may have
noticed that the intro song that they play in the
title is just a little bit different from the
normal intro song just a different version it
sounds really cool all the music for mandalorian
is great but the episode was directed by rick
famoue who also directed bill burr's episode
during season one it was season one episode six
number nine to the prison planet so they go to
the new republic prison planet where bill burr's
character mayfield is being held he's working in
the scrap yards which is basically like the worst
possible work they could give him you probably
recognize all kinds of easter eggs all over
the scrap fields here most of the stuff they're
breaking down here are pieces of old tie fighters
and imperial ships but you notice that there's
also at-at walkers that they've converted in the
background acting like giant claw machines picking
stuff up and carrying it around there was also a
similarly converted at-at walker during season
2 episode 3 back on trask on the water world
it's just a fun way to show you how the new
republic is making use of all this old imperial
tech like okay we'll just reuse this and turn it
into something new that we can use you also notice
that the security droid that's on patrol and
starts talking to mayfield has the new republic
insignia on it his prisoner number is 34667 that's
not a direct reference to any big star wars number
or anything like that but cara dune shows up using
her status as a new republic officer to transfer
him into her custody as he walks away slowly you
notice there's a wolfman prisoner as he walks
by breaking down an at-st walker he's the same
type of alien from the most eisley cantina and
a new hope their race is called the shistavanan
you see the slave one in the background as they
crest the hill then boba fett and fennec shand
walk out you notice that boba fett has cleaned
and polished his armor since the last episode and
bill burr starts making a whole bunch of jokes
he did this with the entire episode pretty much
making fun of every single member of their crew
the mando joke that he makes about boba fett
though is that oh i thought that you were this
other guy that i used to know just as he turns to
reveal that mando is walking down the ship i love
the way he reacted to a lot of this too he was
actually great in the episode like he immediately
sours at the thought of mando needing him for a
mission like oh you know what i'll just go back
to the prison i would rather hang out with them
than hang out with you guys they need him for all
the old imperial codes and protocols which is a
nice callback to return to the jedi where they use
the stolen shuttle tidarium in the older codes to
get past the imperial blockade and land on endor
they're basically doing the same thing to get on
moff gideon's ship so that they can rescue grogu
they also kind of did the same thing during
rogue one too when they were stealing the
death star plans there were also some other
rogue one easter eggs that showed up during
this episode too because of what they were doing
number eight inside the slave one we actually get
a really good look at how the ship works how the
interior passenger section mostly stays stationary
while the ship itself rotates position all over
the place it's a much more sophisticated setup
than the toys have previously made it seem in
the models there'll definitely be some new toy
versions of this eventually and some new toy
versions of this version of boba fett you also
notice he's walking around without his jet pack
on mostly i think that's because of where he's
sitting in the seat like he wasn't really part of
this mission aside from flying the slave one for
support so it wasn't like he needed his jet pack
or his rocket bill burr remembers grogu calling
him the little green guy he didn't manhandle him
too badly during season 1 episode 6. it was the
droid that was actually trying to kill him the
droid that showed up during season 2 episode 2.
mayfield tells them about the secret mining
operation on morack that the empire has had
this whole time and that they're still using the
remnant of the empire at this point the really
special mineral that they're mining there the one
that's so volatile is a key component in starship
fuel and a lot of other things that they power
like they talk about operation cinder it'd be like
having a giant secret oil refinery number seven
while they're making their plans of infiltration
you notice that boafette is not wearing his
helmet this is more foreshadowing for mando
taking his helmet off later during the episode
and possibly more in future seasons as well
you feel like this season there have been so many
mandalorians walking around without their helmets
on that now he's the weird one like no we don't
do this at all it's just you weird mandalorians
from the death watch that do this helmet stuff
mayfield also explains that it's the imperial
security bureau that runs these kind of secret
facilities that's the same branch of the empire
that moff gideon came up in before he became
a moth they're also the branch that runs that
secret base on scarif during rogue one where
they're going to steal the death star plans from
they start talking about the security measures how
they take genetic scans to scan for new republic
infiltrators or people that have shown up in new
republic databases so they know who to kill and
who to allow in they all make jokes about why
they can't be the ones to go with cara doom
because they'll be spotted immediately boba fett
also jokes that they might recognize his face
quote unquote that's just a reference to all
the work he did for darth vader in the empire
during the original trilogy movies also funny
call back to the clone wars and attack of the
clones because if they were to scan him with his
helmet off he would scan genetically like all the
other clones like wait a minute you're one of the
clones what are the clones doing here we thought
they all died off they used juggernaut tanks
during the episode that's actually a big easter
egg for clone wars episodes revenge of the sith
in the prequel movies and the original trilogies
way back when they were developing empire strikes
back joe johnston actually developed a special
tank that was going to be used during the big
assault eventually george lucas decided not to
use that and use the atat walkers instead but
when it came time to make revenge of the sith
george lucas brought the designs back and just
beefed them up big time like they wound up using
much bigger versions and then dave filoni also
used the same tanks during the clone wars series
mando winds up being the one to go with him but
because he wants to hide his face they wind up
stealing the uniforms off the other stormtrooper
guards cara dune dropping down the hatch taking
them out is another nice return of the jedi
reference to chewbacca and the ewoks taking
over the ats t walker then number six bill bird
just tells all kinds of jokes about how bad the
guards smell it's just a reference to them always
stealing stormtrooper armor but nobody talks about
how much people sweat inside that armor because it
probably gets really really hot mando has to trust
cara dune to keep his best car armor safe it's
probably his second most precious item next to
grogu per the end of the episode he will be back
with me soon we'll get to that in a second too
as they roll in though bill burr just lays into
mando just joking trying to get him to talk
talking about his rules trying to make fun of him
a little bit what would they think on mandalore
which is also a nice reminder for the bo katan
in night owl's storyline they'll come back around
eventually i don't know if they're going to show
up during the finale but they'll at least show up
during season 3. they make a couple references to
the planet mandalore during the episode he starts
joking about the technicalities behind the rules
of taking his helmet off is it that you're not
allowed to show your face or take your helmet off
because those are two completely different things
it's all just foreshadowing for him eventually
taking his helmet off later in the episode
the scene of them rolling through the mining town
and him looking at the little kids thinking about
his own childhood being a foundling is just meant
to back up the whole philosophical debate that
bill burr's character mayfield was bringing up
in the episode the empire the new republic it's
all the same the mandalorians you think about all
those people that fought in all those wars that
you guys killed are they any different from what's
happening now technically he's not wrong although
at this point in the episode you still feel like
he's kind of a dirtbag he doesn't really redeem
himself till the end of the episode he even makes
references to alderaan saying what does it matter
now those rules because both of those planets are
gone like i said though mandalore the planet is
not gone it's actually just being occupied by the
new empire moff gideon's forces right now that'll
all come back around in future seasons maybe
there'll be some kind of reference again during
the finale but there's so many other story lines
to wrap up that i feel like they're going to save
a lot of this stuff for future seasons in a lot
of the spin-off series then number five the big
pirate attack so the other imperial juggernauts on
the comms getting attacked by pirates they start
blowing up mando has to take care of them while
bill burr keeps the juggernaut steady so that they
don't blow too because not only are the pirates
trying to blow them up with thermal detonators
the minerals so volatile if they don't keep
juggernaut steady and slow enough it'll blow
anyway mando gets some good takedowns he has
a pretty good fight scene it's just meant to
keep the tension up but the other really important
thing happening during this is the fact that you
notice all the pirates tend to use pole arms why
is this well it's because of that best scar spear
in hyping up the big fight that mando is going to
have with moff gideon during the finale with his
best car spear in the darksaber so just notice
how much mando uses these pole arms he throws
one of them he starts fighting with one of them
he's actually pretty good but if you didn't see
my video from a couple days ago pedro pascal
was the red viper oberyn martel during game of
thrones season 4 and his trademark weapon was
a giant spear they said on game of thrones open
martell's fighting style was actually wu shu so
i don't know if that's going to be similar on the
mandalorian or if they're going to change up the
fighting style a little bit but you just kind of
picture it in your head watching this happen then
you get the big reveal of the empire rolling in to
save them after they get the rug pulled out from
under them and they play this heroic music it's
meant to be kind of a funny juxtaposition with the
other mandalorians from season one episode three
rolling in to rescue him and bill burr also kind
of digging into him a little bit like you never
thought that you'd be happy to see stormtroopers
yay empire thanks for saving us they even get a
big hero's welcome when they roll in it's a little
bit like them coming in after blowing up the death
star at the end of a new hope then number 4 mando
has to take his helmet off so the terminal they
need is in the officer's mess but bill burst is
one of his former commanders so mando goes in
but has to take his helmet off to get the
genetic scan to unlock the terminal he winds
up getting the codes but this is such a huge
deal him taking his helmet off in broad daylight
now we saw him do it during season 1 episode 4 but
that was with him still upholding his rules doing
it when no one else was looking because he does
have to eat at some point he does have to drink
in earlier this season we also saw him kind of tip
his helmet up a little bit when they were drinking
soup together on the razor crest a lot of you've
also asked if grogu has seen mando with his helmet
off and i believe that he knows what he looks
like he probably got a little peek when they
were drinking soup but i don't think he's ever
fully taken his helmet off with grogu around
so technically you could say grogu has not
seen his face so all this stuff with mando
taking his helmet off in this episode and kind of
putting the rules aside doing what he has to do so
that he can sleep at night because he's trying to
rescue grogu i think this is all building towards
a big reveal of him showing his face to grosgu
we'll see what the armorer has to say about this
when she shows up again because she's still
alive out there somewhere you may recognize
valon hess here he's being played by richard
brake he was joe chill during batman begins
and he also played the night king from game of
thrones season 4 in the oathkeeper episode in
that post-credits scene where they were creating
the new white walker in the lands of always winter
he was also the actor who played the night king
during game of thrones season 5 in the hard home
episode the number three bill burr rushes in to
save mando before he gets found out but winds up
killing his commander anyway in retribution for
operation cinder their designation numbers tk593
and tk111 weren't any big references to anything
but when they mention tanab that's actually a big
planet in star wars lore it showed up during a
bunch of different stories they used it during
the thrawn trilogy remember we have grand admiral
thrawn and they're using a lot of thrawn trilogy
easter eggs in the mandalorian series so far it
showed up during old republic stories it showed up
during the great sith war story it was mentioned
during return of the jedi during rogue squadron
in a bunch of the other legends books bill burr
also mentions tps reports which is a nice office
space reference but number two is their toasting
to operation cinder if you don't know what that is
it's actually from the battlefront game but it's
actually a pretty big piece of star wars history
operation cinder is basically one of the emperor's
contingency plans if he were to ever die operation
cinder is basically a scorched earth policy if he
can't rule the galaxy then no one else is going to
have it so what they did is they developed this
technology with a bunch of arrays that would
basically burn planets to the ground after the
emperor was dead they would only be able to use it
one planet at a time but that's what he's talking
about when he says that his entire division like
ten thousand men wound up dying that day so it's
all just part of bill burr's redemption story
during the episode making him seem like less
of a dirt bag and more like mando which he was
trying to tell mando during the episode it's just
that it took to him killing his commander before
he paid that off he even does mando a solid
and says here's your helmet back i won't tell
anybody that i saw your face you also learned a
little bit more about moff gideon's grand plans
for the galaxy i suppose grand admiral thrawn's
plans as well because technically it seems like
they're working together behind the scenes the
commander says that the shipment and mineral that
they delivered is actually going to help the new
empire create so much havoc in the galaxy it'll
make operation cinder seem like small potatoes
and in the chaos the galaxy will turn to the
old empire again for stability so this is a way to
remind you that there are many different parts to
moff gideon's plans for the future of the galaxy
and bringing the empire back it's not just about
the dark troopers it's not just about the outer
rim one final act of redemption bill burr blows
up the mineral that they collected and the others
that they had stockpiled so they won't be able
to use this and whatever crazy plan that they had
to create havoc as the commander said and as they
escape in the slave 1 boba fett takes out the tie
fighters using the same charges that jango fett
used during attack of the clones when he was being
chased by obi-wan kenobi on their way to geonosis
i love the way that they let bill burr go too like
the slow reveal like he's not quite sure what's
going on he doesn't totally trust the situation
like he thinks for a second they might kill him
then just kind of walks off slowly into the
distance like all right see you guys smell you
later but then back on moff gideon's cruiser they
deliver mando's message to him which is a nice
twist on the speech that moff gideon gave them at
the end of season one he means more to me than you
will ever know it's just him throwing the gauntlet
for this big finale battle they're going to have
but number one talking about some of the big
reveals and the mandalorian spin-offs that
they announced yesterday so they confirmed that
there's going to be a star wars ahsoka series
with rosario dawson's character it's going to be
set during the same time period as the mandalorian
so all that stuff with grand admiral thrawn the
teaser at the end of episode 5 that'll probably
be covered on her series as well as tracking down
ezra bridger i also kind of expect sabine wren to
show up on that series maybe tamara morrison will
also come back as rex during that show because rex
is also still alive right now probably one of the
biggest reveals though is that hayden christensen
is coming back as darth vader during obi-wan
kenobi series and they said that that's going
to be 2022 but the next star wars movie to hit
theaters is actually going to be directed by patty
jenkins of all people so i'm actually kind of
excited about that it's going to be rogue squadron
so i'm assuming it's going to be set during the
original trilogy era around rogue one or something
like that i will do a star wars ahsoka trailer and
obi-wan kenobi series trailer with the rogue one
footage and all that stuff later this weekend so
as long as you have alerts enabled for my channel
you should see all those videos my next video will
be for the marvel loki trailer so that should post
later today while you wait for everything click
here for my full mandalorian season 2 episode
6 video and all the other episodes and click
here for all my marvel and star wars trailers
from disney investor day thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe this is the way!